hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play los the lines ok my theory
that I left you Oh at the cliffhanger
last time was that where the monster
came out in the other room
Ivan read comments cuz I record this
straight after but well if one of you
suggested it then good for you you're on
the same same line of thought that I am
in the in the room where the monster
came out of back there and the other
side I bet behind him there's even more
because you know that makes sense we go
back I'm gonna go back please
please can I thank you I almost busted
through the ceiling there this is oh
yeah this is the bug this is where this
is where I fall through the world whoops
oh no wait a minute something else
what was that was like a whole nother
area was that the tomb I don't know I
don't know hard to see complete darkness
falling dying dying dead I'm not
sleeping you're not kidnapping me
I'm just gonna respawn dick dick
yeah I just respawned you doosh doosh
doosh there was a whole nother area
there though
maybe I wasn't supposed to fall through
the world maybe there was like some box
that I pushed out of the way to get to I
mean I have to go all the way back but
let me try this first Oh God so dark and
I'm officially out of oil now shut up
[ __ ] off don't scare me you don't scare
me nothing scares me okay I'm thinking
yeah that would make sense because the
monster did come out of an area so if I
go back there oh it's a brightly lit now
it was so dark before this is nice hi
Billy Mays here okay
now come in here there's that flashy guy
go through here go in here oh oh it's
closed now kidding me oh come on
gotta be joking gotta be joking me it's
closed now Rica frack frazzle dazzle
alright I guess my only hope now is that
if I go back I'll be able to
are you thinking I see you like shadows
just be figure standing I don't know my
mind is breaking if I go back and I look
for the area there must have been some
other way I bet I bet they didn't the
game maker didn't make it so that you
had to fall through the bug hole in the
door and die there was something else I
saw it I saw something else I did I did
hey don't close on me some ghost did
that serious I keep seeing like just in
the distance like this shape of a looks
like the Slenderman this long lanky
shape he's just there in the game but
whatever I'm freaking myself out for no
reason aw was this aunt there's no great
whoosh and then my fall get hurt
i'ma hurt myself Boosh all right this
way awesome suck it up you loser oh no
their problem let me get the chair
there's a chair sure I know there is I
know there is I hope you guys can't see
your thing right now but I know there's
a uh-huh there it is
got it what was that you guys hear that
I'm like a dog growling
something I'm just going crazy I swear
I'm new-school raizy okay let's just
head back to where we need to go and
then get out of here there has to be
something else that I've missed
there has to be
okay I swear you'd
that's not bucket
where is awesome
you know what's this smell this
what the hell is this
what's going on here this wasn't here
before either way
I'm gonna present shapes on the corners
of my eyes not good not good not bode
well for my sanity come on oh come on
there we go okay now because I saw
something else there must be something
right something that I'm just missing
light I can't even see if I'm at the
door I don't want to fall through the
door again okay here we go now if I push
this out of the way or maybe up above
there a way to go through am I supposed
to use used to stack up somewhere
there's got to be something else behind
there no confusing Oh dark Oh
see anything that I don't see like
anything ceiling I don't see and he has
a hole besides this one over here so I
guess I don't know just take a couple of
these boxes and go maybe I need to bring
one of these boxes in the hole with me
back down don't be like that
don't push it away really no what was
that glass oh damn it
really [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] like this
I swear I swear [ __ ]
I keep checking like I swear I see
something something out of the corner of
my eye
okay now all that give it to me
are you I see the hand I see the
freaking hand it just disappears
oh don't be messing with me fine
whatever I got this other one Hopa Duke
I don't know what the hell this would do
what could this does me I don't think it
doesn't mean any good man where the hell
was that thing I saw like I don't know
I'm so confused and I'm just running
around in circles I'm seeing things out
of Maya how did I stand up really I just
I stood up really I can run now it's
phenomenal I suppose over there there
there all these other paths down
different grapes that I can't maybe one
of them is just a fake braid Megan
actually I don't know let me try a bomb
running like that get out of my way
[ __ ] get out of my way oh god damn it
I gotta get the box come here boxy gummy
a boxy come on can't run with you
please get this great out of the way
thank you that's a stupid idea
ah I got stuck a stupid idea anyway I'm
taking this box though it's gotta be
something else that I'm missing because
I did see that whole other area and
there's gotta be something to that it
just has to be if there is it's not
obvious wait a minute I go through the
ceiling there aha
oh wait no there's no ceiling I'm an
idiot there's nothing there
boxy [ __ ] fine screw that damn box I
don't care
there's nothing over here and now I
can't see [ __ ] again jam in my eyeballs
dammit
okay there was nothing over here there
was nothing to be had taken laudanum
okay there was nothing over here that's
completely blocked off from what I saw I
forget like past that there is something
that was like that place to go up like
an elevator or something I'm guessing
that's how you get in the tomb
maybe it's just bugged and one of those
doors is supposed to open up to the tomb
it's just not right now because it's
just a giant piece of [ __ ] I mean that
has to be it right that no there
wouldn't be any other way right there be
there wouldn't be stupid enough to just
not have something to have a room where
my only option to get out is die that's
got to be something in there a button
anything that I just missed get me and
please please let me hand why do you do
this to me why why why do you do this to
me
I could freaking stand up and run in
here you're not gonna let me in all this
is such [ __ ] Anakin [ __ ] ah I click
the damn ladder oh my god this is the
worst kind of [ __ ] I'm seeing I'm
like like my whole experience with this
game is being ruined because of this
piece of [ __ ] area and again [ __ ]
hell
why can't I get through this [ __ ]
hole again [ __ ] got to be kidding me
you've got to be kidding me
you got to be [ __ ] me this is
[ __ ] this is just [ __ ]
grade-a [ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm trying oh you gotta be kidding me
you gotta be joking me you've got
[ __ ] hell let me through
oh you piece of [ __ ] there finally God
we should a [ __ ] minute and a half
trying to get in here mother [ __ ] and
now I'm not running
man this is a shitty level time shitty I
don't care if it's unique it's [ __ ] this
is one where it does not work get very
pissed great eh
don't don't
ah what why he does this happen why is
this this way
this bug [ __ ] central [ __ ] here so
even if there was something ipod can't
see it cuz I don't have any lantern oil
and this is nothing just this whole
episode just a dot pile up [ __ ] let
me go through the bug in the door fine
whatever
whatever doesn't matter doesn't matter I
don't care I don't care I don't care
okay okay
smash okay it's all the same to me I'll
never find the tomb but that's okay
because [ __ ] that and [ __ ] this players
this whole area there was nothing there
I looked everywhere I looked everywhere
where else could I have gone do I have
all this stuff for the machine or do I
not because I can't use any of this
stuff that I have on it what is going on
with this game was that something
if it was something I couldn't see it so
whatever yeah my way
seriously we just have this I have the
three things I see three holes there
there are three [ __ ] saying 1 3 and 2
what the [ __ ]
and it reads that I can use it on it
can't use that item this way
can't use the item this way can't use
the item this way can't use the item
this way even though it says to and I
have something that says to
god damn I'm just so pissed right now is
there some other door in here that I
would love to find in the dark I'm out
of time
[ __ ] hell all right sorry about this
episode guys thanks for watching
shut up [ __ ] I'm seeing [ __ ] out of
the corner of my eyes going crazy can't
see [ __ ] got no oil I'm just [ __ ]
lost alright next episode I'm gonna
figure out what to do before I start
recording like I did [ __ ] I'm not
gonna waste you guys it's time with me
just floundering like this so thanks
everyone so much for watching and as
always I'll see you in the next part
bye-bye